people say this all the time people say
Iran is the state sponsor of largest
state sponsor of terrorism in the world
what does that mean it means that they
have built up proxies right
um in in the Middle East in part to uh
satisfy their one of their primary
objectives which is to destroy Israel so
they have built essentially and
sponsored and funded and trained and
resourced Hezbollah up in Lebanon um uh
Hamas um Palestinian Islamic Jihad um
and the houis in in Yemen I I'll stick
with those three for now but they're all
creations essentially of Israel or of uh
Iran if if Iran didn't provide them with
support and funding and guidance and
training and missiles and weapons um you
know we wouldn't be talking about this
today
Let's uh let's shift to some of the
fires in the world right now there are
many fires but as we sit here as we sit
here right now just I think about two
hours ago the Biden Administration has
reinstated the houthis as a terrorist
organization yeah um they were a
terrorist organization under Trump Biden
one of the first things he came in and
did was undo that now we got a big
problem can you explain who the houth
give me like houie 101 what's going on
in Yemen can you clean that up for for
the average person that's watching
another fire in the world and going why
should I care why does this matter you
know yeah yeah yeah so the yeah the
hoties um we see the dancing videos
they've got a great choreographer over
there get their guys out there with the
music and I tell you what you want to I
mean sa the capital of Yemen is a is a
fascinating place right um it's very
interesting it's an interesting culture
it's it's a a really you know and that's
the thing you look at and go okay well
you guys are pretty up but it's a
it's a fascinating Place great history
great culture let's let's get this under
control but they they basically have had
a civil war in Yemen uh raging for quite
some time and I I don't want to
oversimplify this
but um a lot of the violence a lot of
the death a lot of the instability uh in
that region if you're say well what the
hell's going on it's essentially a Sunni
Shia problem right so the Saudis you
know Sunni um Iran Shia right if if if
you know nothing else about it then just
you you kind of say okay yeah you got
two teams and they're they're and
they're going at each other in terms of
of of their belief systems um Iran has
been supporting the houis they they find
it uh in their best interest Iran is
people say this all the time people say
Iran is the state sponsor of largest
state sponsor of terrorism in the world
what does that mean it means that they
have built up proxies right
um in in the Middle East in part to uh
uh satisfy their one of their primary
objectives which is to destroy Israel so
they have built essentially and
sponsored and funded and trained and
resourced Hezbollah up in Lebanon um
Hamas um Palestinian Islamic Jihad um
and the hutis in in Yemen I I'll stick
with those three for now but they're
all creations essentially of Israel or
of uh Iran if if Iran didn't provide
them with support and funding and
guidance and training and missiles and
weapons um you know we wouldn't be
talking about this today right because
Hamas wouldn't wouldn't be anywhere near
where it is right um but they do Iran's
bidding in a sense I'm oversimplifying a
little bit they've got their own
interests as well but but that's where
they take their guidance from for the
most part so you've got uh you've got
the hooti sitting in
Yemen they claim that they've started
this latest issue this this this this
rocketing of commercial and now US Navy
warships in the Red Sea in sympathy and
support of Hamas right and uh against
Israel it's not as if the houis sat
there to themselves you know they
they're in a very tenuous ceasefire
right now and and their their uh their
conflict with the they don't control
they're not recognized as the government
of of Yemen um the government the
recognized government of Yemen is
supported by the Saudis right um the
houti supported by the Iranians but
there's a very tenuous ceasefire there
that exists it's not as if the houis
would have said to themselves on their
own without Iranian encouragement and
guidance you know what we should do we
should take some of these Iranian
provided missiles and anti- ship
missiles and start blasting them out and
really disrupting global trade that the
Red Sea channel that that accounts for
you know 15% 17% of of global Shipping
traffic right um most major Shipping
Lines Maris kapag lloid um and most
major companies shell U BP others just
shut down their operations they're
rerouting all their traffic around uh
the Cape of Good Hope so that adds extra
days adds about nine days on on
depending on the routes we're talking
about that's fuel costs that's crew
costs that's shipping that's it's just
everything gets into that uh everything
starts to to become a problem and so the
hoties it's not like did this on their
own
um what our problem is from a US
perspective and our allies perspective
is that the Biden Administration
currently um won't
address the primary driver of all this
which is Iran right so the Iranians made
the calculation the regime not the
people the history of Iran's fantastic
right um and the people are great but
it's the regime and the rgc the
Revolutionary guard Corps they know
because they've been doing this for a
long time that they can continue to
destabilize the region and they're not
going to be paying for it directly right
any any response is going to be directed
at one of their proxies right so that
was that was a calculation they made the
Biden Administration is is playing that
out for sure you know they early on in
the conflict they didn't want to talk
about Iran right now they've at least
mentioned it obliquely this
designation that you rais is interesting
because president Trump did designate
them as a foreign terrorist organization
you've got different levels of
designation right when you when you say
okay that group Hamas or that group over
there we want to designate them as
terrorists you can you can do that at
various levels and it has different
impacts in terms of what actions can
then be taken against the
group so the Trump Administration listed
houis as a foreign terrorist
organization and then um I know Trump in
February of 21 or sorry Biden when he
came in so it was February of 2021
reversed that decision and he reversed
it because the UN and others were saying
oh this is terrible you know you can't
keep them on the terrorist list because
it's hurting you know Yemen it's hurting
the people of Yemen and you know they're
not getting humanitarian Aid and and
well you know most of that humanitarian
Aid was getting rifled through by the by
the hotties anyway right lead exactly
like what's happened with Hamas and with
Hezbollah EXA that's exactly right yeah
Hamas is the leadership is Rich because
of all the billions that they control
when money and Aid goes into Gaza right
they so anyway but with the with the
hoties the the bid administration had no
choice I think from an optic from for
politics um they realized okay we now
have to reverse our own decision so now
they've this we you mean they had no
choice now then you think then the the
idea was well Trump did it so we're just
going to reverse it Ence yeah I think
like everything else with the Border
decisions you know that they took on the
border ridiculous right but it was that
idea that like if Trump did it it must
have been bad yeah right and so let's
let's just change it all because that'll
show how righteous we are right so they
did that with the houis um and now now
they've decided to go and reverse their
thinking because they have no choice
right I mean the news the media has
finally picked up on this and said okay
there's a lot going on here and we're
being targeted uh it's only a matter of
time you know before something bad
happens and then so I think they wanted
to get ahead of it a little bit right um
and so what they've done is they haven't
gone with the foreign terrorist
organization designation they went with
a lesser designation which
is especially designated Global
terrorist right so whatever that is
that's an acronym I'm sure it's a
government acronym SG DT right so um
that is still important no don't get me
wrong I'm glad they did it but um it's
not the strongest that they could the
action that they could take against the
hoodies so what they've done here is
they're saying okay you know we're going
to designate you as terrorists yeah
we're going to call you terrorists but
and that can allow us to to freeze
Assets in to a degree but that still
allows for humanitarian Aid to go in uh
again the problem is if it goes into H
if it goes into the port main Port there
in in uh in in Yemen that's controlled
by uh the houis so humanitarian Aid will
you know whether it gets to the actual
people who deserve it need it Etc just
like with the citizens of Gaza yeah um
yeah is is anybody's guess how much of
this of the craziness that we're seeing
right now whether it's in Gaza or
whether it's in Yemen and what's going
on with the with Red Sea and everything
is connected back to the $6 billion
dollar that just you know a couple weeks
before October 7th they were saying oh
well it's it's fungible who knows what
they're going to do with it after they
had originally said no we can't go to
certain things and then suddenly it was
like oh we gave him the cash well we'll
see yeah yeah don't know yeah we we
can't keep track of our own money here
I'm sure we can watch it you know money
going out of flowing out of cutter for
uh for for the Iranians yeah I you know
what I think it was a it was definitely
the wrong move it was a stupid move uh
it was misguided on their part um did it
contribute to what's going on now not
really because the Iranians have been
making Bank off of oil anyway right
they've been making money so I'm not
saying that the six billion wasn't
important because it was right and um
and in other additional funds that were
going there know it was that wasn't the
only TR of money that went to the
Iranian regime uh from the Biden
Administration but they were making
money anyway because we haven't we
haven't clamped down on on you know
their primary source of Revenue which is
energy right same with Russia you know
we made the same mistake with Putin and
you know the Iranians are are selling
and you know from to China and Russia um
so they have buyers right um but it does
point to just this misguided foreign
policy that the B Administration has had
towards Iran and I get it you know they
they were doing what they believed in
you know Administration comes in they
they're going to make their own
decisions but it
seems it
seems opposite of what history has told
us right every time us is extended their
hand right to you know try to you know
make some deal or negotiate or make
peace with the oran they just the regime
smacks it away right and they keep on
doing what they've been doing and so uh
I don't know why they expected to get
some different reaction if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell